và gai một số thông một các tổ chức quan sát của tế tại Iran cho biết
ít nhất 25 người là thình mạng trong là sống biểu tình kinh tế đã kéo dài chính ngày qua tại Iran
Đây là hộ qua từ đồng lỗi tệ mất giả mạnh và lặng phát nèo thang tới 1 mức hình chăm
Kéo số liệu từ các tổ chức của tế trong số các bạn nhớ nơi dưới mấy tạm tôi
Đông thời hơn 1 người đã bị bắt
một số tổ chức khác thậm chí cho rằng đã có ít nhất 25 người chết
bao gồm 2 thành viên được Ấn ninh, cùng hơn 1 người 2 trăm vụ bắt giữ tình đến ngày 1 năm thông một
Giờ chức Iran không cũng nhận cú nhiều không khẳng định như có số mà các tổ chức này được ra
Chính quyền Tế Iran chỉ sẵn nhận ít nhất 20 người viên thuộc lực lượng an ninh kinh mạng
và hẳng chủc này khác bị thương
Hẹn không trao biểu tình kinh tế tại Iran đã lan xong nhiều thành phố Ưm ình tới và miền nằm đến lức
Dù quy mô nhỏ hơn phong trao phản đối năm 2020, các cuộc súng được là nãy nhánh trong ước khỏi yêu cầu kinh tế
và mạnh nhà xuất hiện khổ hiệu chỉ trích cả nhân lặng
và giới chính chỉ cộng quyền
Chỉ vụ Iran đứng đầu là tổng thống mi xuất về dịch sẻa nghe nhận khổ khăn kinh tế và kêu gọi đối thoại
và nhỏ miểu tình ổng hoa ông đồng thời gian kết cả các nhằm ổn định hệ thống tình tế trong buổi cạnh
Đồng Rhean tiếp tục mất giả và sử ước chế của các cuộc tổn hành chưa có giấu hiệu hành nhận
Theo Tế Iran các biển pháp trở cắt sớm nhất để sóa dụ tình hình sẽ có hiệu lực từ ngày 1 mồi tham ổn